So 2^n, if instances are smaller than 10 that means that the running time will be
around 1000 time units or 1024 time units to be precise.
If it's 20, you will have about 1 million time units.
If it's 30, you will have about 1 billion time units. So 1 thousand times 1 thousand times 1 thousand.
If it's larger than 100, then of course you have a huge running time here.
You will have a running time that is about 10³⁰.
It's clear that when your instances get larger than 100, you would not be able to use brute force.
And on the other hand, if you just need 1000 time units, I think you don't even care if you have
1 instance or 100 or 10,000 because if you think about it a current desktop computer
is running on gigahertz so it can perform several billion operations per second.
Even solving 10,000 instances where each one is small is usually not an issue unless
you're working in a very special environment.
What about a million time units? I would clearly say well solving that once is okay.
Again, your computer can perform several billion operations per second.
Solving 100 instances is usually okay and even solving 10,000 instances.
So 10,000 times 1 million that's 10 billion, which sounds like a lot but actually again
desktop computers can handle this in most cases.
Now what about this case here? Well, 1 billion is okay. We just said that over here.
And we said even 10 billion was okay. So what about 100 billion?
Well, this I think here is kind of debatable but I would still say it's worth a try probably.
Then you have to probably wait for two or three or four days until all instances are solved
or maybe even one month but in most cases that should be okay.
You wouldn't even attempt to solve NP-commplete problem in real time for example.
This one here I think is the most debatable.
So 10,000 billion I would say in a general case you wouldn't want to do that.
I mean, there might be special cases if you work for the secret service
and you have a huge cluster of computers available but here you're kind of
reaching the limits of brute force and here of course as we just said you've already reached that.
So again, brute force can work if the instances are small or maybe even moderate
but this approach is bound to fail at some point and that's when to apply intelligence
instead of brute force using intelligent force.